in today's edition of unicorn dust we're
going to review we're talking about the
5070 Fe still confused as to why they
didn't make a 570 TI Fe but since this
one is an actual Fe card maybe it'll
help with MSRP pricing a little bit
probably
not for those looking for a high-end
custom gaming experience look no further
than Falcon Northwest Falcon Northwest
has been building PCS made for gamers
for over 30 years with a focus on a true
high-end gaming experience custom cases
available only through Falcon Northwest
feature state-of-the-art testing and
design to sure that every component is
performing at their best through thermal
imaging and rigorous lab testing
designed and overseen by the Falcon
Northwest founder himself with a
complete lineup of systems ranging from
small to large every Falcon Northwest
system includes a three-year warranty
policy and a year of two-way overnight
shipping coverage providing the ultimate
pce of mind to see all that Falcon
Northwest has to offer follow the
sponsored Link in the description below
all right so this is the Nvidia Founders
edition of the uh RTX 5070 uh embargo
lift this today they go on shelves
tomorrow the
whatever the date is the 5th of March is
when they're actually going to be on
shelves theoretically uh we're only
going to be reviewing the Fe we're not
doing any partner cards this time around
so Usual Suspects uh when it comes to
the type of review we're going to do
here we got average FPS 95th percentile
99th percentile in terms of FPS uh we
did some power testing and a little bit
of Investigation as to why we were
actually getting some pretty poor 1%
lows with this card so I got some
interesting visualized data for you guys
to see um and uh yeah so we tested a lot
of cards for this and the included some
AMD stuff and this may not be as
exciting to talk about today because the
Embargo lift is tomorrow for the 970 and
970 XT so I have a feeling a lot of
people are going to probably be sitting
on pins and needles really seeing how
those cards compare considering the
pricing has finally been announced uh
speaking of pricing this is a $549 MSRP
RP card which is exactly the MSRP of
the9 70 non XT and the 970 XT comes in
at $5.99 so it is getting very crowded
in that $550 to $600 price point um
unfortunately since there is no Founders
Frontier SL reference card for the 97970
XT that might be a free-for-all when it
comes to pricing so anyway moving
forward uh 549 um MSRP if you look at
the styling on it it definitely looks
like I'm holding a 90 like it's I'm a
big dude like people see me in real life
they're like oh my God you are way
taller and way bigger than I expected uh
so just I feel I feel like a giant
holding the 590 this is a 90 I'm just
that big no this is a 90 right here so
it's just like little brother like
literally uh notably it is not a pass
through cooler um if you can imagine how
small the piece B would have to be
although I bet you anything they could
have done it with this card if they
wanted to um so it is not a true
flowthrough design this side is fully
open though the PCB does have a curve
made uh built into it so that the air
can pass through and then the air going
in this fan does exhaust out the back of
the case as you can see with the vent
right there in a very traditional layout
um which is pretty much exactly how the
4070 uh design is and then the 37 or the
370 is just a dual axial fan that
exhausts out the rear of the card um
it's right here actually no it is a
blowr I forgot that is one of the first
blowr they did whatever um that's old
though no one wants to play with that
anymore okay I kid so talking about key
specifications though there's 6,140 Cuda
cor on the DB 205 core found in the 570
both the 470 and the 3070 have
5,888 Cuda cores but they're on two
different architectures RT core count
though is like really hardly moved at
all it's just obviously running the
fourth gen RT cores in the 5070 a total
48 RT cores 46 found on both 470 and 370
the difference is we have second gen RT
cores found on the 370 and third gen RT
cores found on the 4070 so the
performance uplift you're going to see
when it comes to RT performance is a
generational uplift rather than it being
more of a Brute Force approach of adding
more RT cores um when it comes to tensor
cores we have 192 of the fifth gen
tensor cores found in the 57 or 570 184
of them found in the 470 those are
fourth gen cores and then 184 also in
the 3070 but again third gen cores robs
that's always been an interesting
discussion well actually no it's been a
quite boring discussion that only people
started talking about or even thinking
about because of the fact that they've
been missing on the 50 90 and the 80 and
the 5070 ti so I have zero reason to
assume there won't be 507s that pop up
missing robs as well ours is not though
we are having all 80 uh accounted for so
there's 80 on the 570 64 on the 470 and
interestingly enough 96 of them on the
3070 So based on the date on the box of
when this card was manufactured and when
news started popping up of certain cards
missing uh what appears to be an entire
cluster of RS and when Nvidia says hey
we figured it out I I don't it's weird
that they had it already figured out and
apparently already fixed prior to
anyone's videos going live tells us they
obviously already knew about it and they
hoped nobody would talk about it or
notice but unfortunately we did but
again based on the whole timeline I have
no reason to believe 507s won't pop up
with some missing clusters either um
it's just all to bunched together and
they're all coming from the same mass
manufactured wafer and whatever is
causing uh some of those RS to get fused
off has not been totally discovered yet
so just know if you buy a 5070 you might
end up missing some RS just the timing
is all too close together so the 5070
has 12 GB of gddr 7 an 192bit bus it's a
PCI and pcie Gen 5 device which as we
know in the 5090 barely means anything
so obviously means nothing on the 55070
for a uh total uh memory throughput of
672 GB per second bandwidth now it's
important to note the 470 also is on 12
gbt of
gddr6 but
the 370 is actually running 8 GB of
gddr6 so you'll notice actually on
stalker 2 in our benchmarks when we get
there and you might have noticed this
also with our 370 TI which is also 8 GB
the game wouldn't run it actually would
run for a few seconds and then
completely the bed uh giving us
about 05 FPS once that frame buffer
became fully utilized so that's why
there are big fat zeros on our chart
because it's the first test we've
actually got with our setting and the
way it's set up on the Epic settings
which is we test everything at almost
Max settings to kind of see what the
worst case scenario would be it's really
the first time we have a hardware that
is too far behind the the requirements
and although they're not 4K cards we
continue to show the data because if you
ever wanted a 4K panel we think it's
important to know what the FPS impact
might be going from something like 1440p
to 4K it's important note the 5070
though is a very strong Contender at
1440p many games is capable 4K if you
lower the settings obviously it's a
1080p card uh no problem whatsoever if
you wanted to run like Esports titles or
whatever and get high frame rates uh
speaking of frame rates and such the
base clock is a 2325 with a boost clock
of 2512 on the 5070 obviously GPU boost
uh logic is going to take over where if
you have plenty of power Headroom and
temperature Headroom it will push those
clocks much higher and our instances it
was pushing them over 2,800 MHz which is
an additional 300 MHz overclock giving
us about 550 MHz of total automatic
overclocking that takes place over the
base clock uh it is a 250 W thermal
design though that's where you start to
realize most of the generational gains
that we're seeing here although it's got
a bump in cacor and such really comes
from 50 Series uh mentality of let's
just turn the power knob up some more I
mean we saw that across the board every
card pulls more power than its previous
uh or versus its predecessor so this is
a 250 watt card the 4070 right here is a
200 watt card versus the 220 watt card
found on the 370 so it's funny the 470
was actually a power drop from 220 to 2
and then now it is 25% more power on the
5070 at 250 Watts so let's talk about
gaming performance here we go and put
the charts up typical fashion uh we're
just going to kind of go through them
we're not going to talk about them just
pause them on the screen you can see
where they land versus uh previous gen
and obviously the higher end card so if
you were considering maybe going with
like a 5070 TI it's on there obviously
if you want to go like 80 or compared to
a 480 or 470 TI or 4070 or 470 super 470
TI super and all the stupid 70s that
exist the one thing to consider here is
the price and performance Gap I really
want you to pay attention to on the
gaming charts as you scroll through
through them is the gap between the 5070
and the 5070 TI not only is there a huge
performance Gap there is a $200 price
gap between the two remember the 5070 TI
uh MSRP price is $7.49 we know that is a
launch number uh there are a handful of
cards out there that exist at that price
point but realistically it is closer to
$850 to $900 which is absolutely
ridiculous and still selling out at that
price which is ridiculous with this
being a $549 card tells me you can
obviously expect a 5070 super at some
point and probably a 5070 TI super which
I don't know how you could do that
theoretically when the 580 is supposed
to be $1,000 unless all this pricing was
always by
Design moving on from pricing it's the
depressing subject we all know and
expect um performance uplift
generationally this is the first time
I've actually done a performance
generation uplift uh graph which is kind
of interesting so if we compare the 570
uplift versus the
470 across the our gaming Suite this
time including our synthetics I want to
include the synthetics to just kind of
show you guys how those impact the
overall numbers we have a
22.1% uh uplift across the board all of
them from 4070 to 40 to
5070 uh
4070 compared to 3070 was actually 32.3
so you can see we're about 10% lower
when compared to the generational uplift
versus 470 now remember it is just a
small tweak on a couple more things a
few more Cuda Cor uh but just pushing
the power limit and the clock as far as
you possibly can now the the thing
that's really pulling that number up
though is cyberpunk coming in at
40.6% uplift from 570 versus 470 but
it's a cyberpunk version 2.12 which
actually really benefits from RT
improvements because we run RT on in our
testing so that one test is actually
pulling it up quite a bit if we just
omit the synthetics and get rid of
cyberpunk entirely
we actually get 19% uplift so you can
see that one title pulled it up 3.1%
just that one title um if we talk about
per title uplift stalker 2 was 18.4
Avatar was 17 Horizon forbidden West is
14.6 Borderlands was
22.1 black myth 20.4 and f124 21.6 so
it's really landing around the
generational uplift we've been seeing
sort of across the board with the
exception of 590 versus 490 um nothing
really to write home about if you could
get this card at 549 it actually would
be a pretty solid Contender for fewer
future facing um gaming when it comes to
AAA titles I didn't even test multi gen
uh or frame gen at all in this
particular generation I'm kind of over
it to be honest or this particular card
let us not
forget this is the card that Jens Sun
probably got up on stage and said RTX
570 4090 performance at
$549 now get the fine print that you've
got to use the magnifying glass from the
Santa Claus movie to be able to read
says when multiframe frame gen uh IND D
lss4 is enabled obviously we didn't do
any of that and if you look at our
gaming charts as you can see it's not
exactly the way it really truly pans out
this in my opinion borderline Border
Lines uh or probably just straight up
crosses the line on false advertising
let's talk about some of the uh more
specific charts here when it comes to
power draw and such so when it comes to
power draw I do two different tests here
I do furmark which is just a straight up
heavy load it's got the fuzzy donut just
rotating around um we use that to test
both temperatures and to test power uh
so if we go and take a look at the uh
furmark temperature test it's kind of
interesting the 5070 it ramps up pretty
quickly actually ramps up faster than
the other two cards uh but then it
levels off and actually starts to dip a
little bit uh so it did surpass about
76.5 C and then level out right at 75c
as the fan curve ramped up it's almost
like the temp overshot the fan curve and
then the fan curve caught up and brought
the temp back down the other two cards
behaved uh exactly as they the the
behavior normally is the fan speed
adjusts more quickly to the load which
means it can sort of keep it from
climbing quite as high as the uh the
5070 did Under full load though even
obviously you would expect more
temperature out of a more power hungry
card so at 250 Watts obviously it
leveling out at 75 degrees the uh 370
which is a 220 watt card leveling out at
approximately
72° and then obviously the 20000 watt uh
RTX 470 leveling out about 66° so the
temperature lands exactly where their
power spacing lands but real world
scenario here we can take a look at uh
cyberpunk
2077 uh when it comes to actual
temperatures the 3070 is actually the
highest or hottest card at just over 70c
the 470 uh capping out at just about 66
and a half degrees and ironically the
5070 coming in as the coolest card
Landing at about 7 or 63.5 cels and the
reason for that is the fact that the
card doesn't actually pull 250 Watts
when you're doing actual gaming it
actually runs out of voltage and clock
speed before it runs out of power in a
real world scenario if you take a look
at the actual power draw in furmark you
can see it's a fairly solid yellow line
for the 5 70 at 200 it says 250 Watts
but remember I measure with the PMD what
the physical power draw is plus the PCI
Express um so it's actually pulling over
260 Watts out of uh total power so it
does overshoot that all the cards do
there's a difference between what
software reports and what actual
physical limitations or physical
measurements are after heat losses and
and other power losses are taken into
account as you can see the 370 Fe kind
of hovering right around 225 to 227 and
then the 4070 has some weird Behavior I
think because it's such a low wat TDP
card and how difficult the fuzzy donut
is to run you see this weird kind of a
wave happening there and as the doughnut
turns it does different things in the
test so you can see which parts of the
test are harder to run based on the
power going up and which parts of the
test are easier to run as the power
starts to go down so it's not a solid
line it's a looks like an ocean wave
which is kind of interesting on that one
but again a 200 watt card uh you can run
out of power before you'll run out of
other limitations uh on that card but
again going to real world power draw
testing and games all of them pull under
their uh well except for the 4070 they
all pretty much pull under their rating
the most efficient card coming in again
is the 5070 Fe in this test at just over
177 watts in real world gaming um one
thing I want to note both the 470 and
the 3070 pull additional power from the
PCI Express 3070 was actually pulling 60
wats from the PCI Express slot with the
rest of the power coming from the uh 8
Pin PCI Express to the uh pre1 12volt
high power adapter it's not quite 12volt
high power but it looks a lot like it uh
it is pulling all of that power UH 60
watts of it from the socket so that or
the slot that's the highest of the three
the uh 4070 is pulling approximately 11
to 12 Watts from the PCI Express slot
and then the 570 is pulling nothing from
the PCI Express slot it pulls one watt
consistently through the PCI Express
slot it is pulling every bit of it
through the 12vt 2x6 or 12vt high power
plug uh but as you can see in this
efficiency chart here it is the lowest
power draw of our 1440p cyberpunk with
rate tracing going uh but 3070 pulling
the most power at about 2117 watts and
then kind of straddling the 200 watt
line is the 4070 cuz again it's super
low watt TDP car therefore it hits the
power limit early now when it comes to
cooling though all three of these cards
do take a slightly different approach to
how the card is cooled all three of them
have a half flow through half uh 90°
turn design but all three of them have
different fans and overall different
shapes so what we're going to do right
now is we'll listen to some sound
profiles of how all three cards sound at
both 50% fan speed which is about the
average we saw the auto fan curve go-to
sometimes 60 sometimes 44 45 so 50% and
100% pay close attention to the the the
sound of the air and its its turbulent
properties because of the fact that all
three of these cards have to make a 90°
turn in Air Flow at least for part of
the cooler it's never going to sound as
smooth as the 590 uh FL double flow
through design does It's actually an
incredible design when it comes to the
Acoustics um but all three of these have
a very different sound profile so take a
listen
[Music]
[Applause]
now let's talk about frame times frame
time all FPS is is a calculation of the
frame times how much in milliseconds it
takes to draw the frame and how many of
those do you get on average per second
this is why we do 95th percentile
basically on the advice of Gamers Nexus
when he came here and gave us some of
the uh ideologies he believed fifth
percentile was actually more important
than 0.1 percentile so we do average we
do 99th percentile and we do 95th
percentile so as you can see the light
blue line is the 370 uh which has the
highest frame times on average if you
take a look at the 4070 obviously it
comes comes down and then the 5070 is
the lowest coming in at about 11.5
milliseconds on average but I want you
to look through the lines here you might
have noticed on the FPS charts that the
5070 had the worst 1% lows for us it was
like in the 3070 1% low range and I went
and just started double-checking all of
our runs the amazing thing about the
fact that every single run is recorded
into a CSV now we can go back and verify
the data make sure we didn't trans or
transcribe something
wrong and the data is what it is and I
noticed something here if you look at
the yellow lines so if we remove the
other uh frame times here and look at
just the 5070 you can see very
consistent frame times uh that have us
this High Spike and they're very
consistent on uh very close in range on
how high they're spiking so I thought
maybe something was potentially off with
the our capture or something on with the
card but started looking at all of our
data for that card on all the runs and
every single game has this ex exact same
weird interval Spike on the frame times
that is why we are getting the really
low 1% lows I can't tell you why it's
spiking like that I can tell you that
this is a pre-release driver which we
have to use cuz it's the only driver
that will recognize the 5070 and work um
I can tell you that behavior did not
happen on any of our other 50 Series
cards 5070 TI 58 80 or 5090 nor any of
the 40 or 307 30 series cards that we
retested to prepare for this launch so I
can't tell you why it's doing that but I
can at least point to this and say this
is why the 1% lows look like complete
trash on the chart so this is something
I'm going to have to go back once we get
like full me uh non-media drivers or
public facing drivers we're going to
have to go through and retest and see if
this continues to happen if it doesn't
then we'll have to rerun our test and
entirely for the 5070 which should give
us some uh more accurate 1% lows but I
don't feel like the overall the data the
data affects the total like opinion on
the card because the average FPS and the
fifth percentile FPS are landing where
we expect them to land versus their
neighboring cards their price point uh
peers as well as their generational
peers that we compare them to it's just
the 1% lows now none of this really was
noticeable when gaming it's not like
it's not like that was a noticeable
stutter in the game it's not like it was
a noticeable hiccup because it's not
like a crazy spike it had been like a
100 milliseconds 200 milliseconds or
something like that that would be very
noticeable but we're talking going from
11 milliseconds up to about 22
milliseconds so it's double the time
which does sound like it would be a
hiccup or a stutter but it actually was
not noticeable so I don't know if it's a
potential reporting thing when it comes
to present Monon we know present Monon
is uh does need some tweaking when it
comes to 50 Series cards especially when
it comes to uh m multi frame gen and
really being able to recognize what
those numbers look like outside of
average FPS so we've got some more
digging to do here but this is the only
card that does that so I don't think
it's necessarily a present Monon thing I
think it's more than likely a driver
thing which shouldn't be all that
surprising giving everything that has uh
been happening with 50 Series launches
at the end of the day I feel that just
about the only card that will probably
be$ 5.49 is the Fe and the Fe is always
the hardest card to get your hands on
and it already hard to get your Hands-On
family of graphics cards this will be
different though because it has direct
competition in its exact price point
launching one day later
so I I find it very difficult for me to
give you any sort of a buy it or skip it
recommendation knowing that in one day a
new player is entering the chat that I
can't talk about yet but I can tell you
this is a very disruptive
very okay look the
5070 this is like Trent you know captain
of the polo team right we'll forget the
other cards right this is captain of the
polo team he's got a girl under each arm
you know it's Nvidia right but then the
new kid wearing like a leather biker
jacket comes in you know just scruffy
hair just really just really doesn't
give a about
Authority that's what you're all going
to see tomorrow
so do me a favor know it's a solid
performing card there is competition
just you just got to wait till tomorrow